hello everyone welcome back to the cup
of Monica saga of course we are back at
the 1914 tournaments of Sankt Petersburg
and Capablanca faces again with the
black pieces the strongest chess
physician in the world
it's dr. Siebert Arash and the first
time they faced off against each other
was in the 1911 Sun Sebastiaan
tournament Tyra had the white pieces he
went for detail and game then the second
time was in the first part of this
second part of the 1914 tournament in
San Peter Berg where Tyrus went for the
reuleaux PES and now again third time
tersh has the white pieces but we
already mentioned this in a previous
video the two of them played six games
all together and out of the six games
tarush had the double white pieces in
five of those games and I don't remember
I mentioned this at the beginning of the
1914 tournament but some of you might
might have forgotten and some of you
might not have been here from the
beginning the Capablanca won the first
part of the tournament being the point
and had ahead of everyone else so he
keeps that point advantage so now in the
second part of the tournament in the
double round-robin Capablanca has a one
and a half point lead ahead of everyone
else so if he just you know doesn't
terribly blunder something he pretty
much has this you know tournament in the
bag now let's check out this very nice
game they will repeat a game from the
first part of the tournament to a
certain point
tarus goes for e4 e5 Knight f3 knight c6
and Bishop to b5 again Torres goes for
the rule opus as he really had an
excellent game and for those of you who
don't remember both the game from the
San Sebastian tournament in 1911 and
from the first part of this tournament
were drawn between the two of them a six
more fees defense again by capablanca as
in the first game here
Bishop a4 Knight to f6 and Knight to c3
Bishop to e7
everything the same as in the first game
and their d3 was played if you remember
that weird the tempo loss by Tara she
played d3 and after d6 he advanced the
pawn all the way to d4 in instead of
just immediately going d4 but here
tarush had a different idea he prepared
for this game
he went castles and okay na capablanca
goes b5 forces the Bushra back Russia b2
b3 and only now d6
we have a four as now capablanca gave
him a target so you do want to attack
that target you know it always prints a
principal idea to attack you know a pawn
would with a less central pawn and here
before not allowing this change and
kicking the night back into the center
nice to be five and this is a pretty
standard position even in today's chest
that has stood the test of time for more
than a hundred years there are some
notable games for example from 2013
ponomaryov versus Sergey Karjakin and
then also most SE and vs. Peter Svidler
but in both of those games
black continued with Knights to a five
which is the engine's top recommendation
but in those days without engines Lasker
went for Bishop to g4 just a nice normal
developing human move so we have c3 and
now comes Luke to b8 and of course c3
takes away the d4 square from black's
knight you don't want to allow the
attacking of the pinned piece and now d4
or d3 is an idea depending on how black
continues and now we have Bishop to c4
Tyrus goes for the ACE exponent which is
now undefended after kappa blanka played
rook to b8 and Capablanca goes for
Knight captures on e4 and here d for by
Tosh
there is one game that was played two
years after this game
it's the game in New York a rice
tournament in 1916 shredder vs. Hodge
where Bishop captures an a6 was played
but the black was able to win this with
that game very elegantly so d4 here by
Terrace maybe Bishop captures an e6 was
supposed to be an improvement on Towers
d4 but it didn't go all that will be
captures on c3 by Capablanca be captures
on c3 and now casts by kappa blanka and
Bishop captures an a6 finally
eke a person d4 seek after Sundy for and
now comes Knights to be for attacking
the bishop on e6
so Bishop either has to go back or you
have to capture as your knight on d5 is
also attacked with Knight captures and
rook captures so Tata shear has a passed
pawn but what does kappa blanka have
Capablanca has well a bit of a lead in
development and also he will be at some
point able to create a pass point
perhaps if c6 will be playable
c5
Bishop to b5 now reducing the mobility
of Capablanca rook and now it's
interesting can capablanca immediately
go for c5 this does instantly create a
passed pawn for kappa blanka as well but
after D captures D captures and for
example if the Queen's come off the
board 95 now comes with an attack on the
bishop and also Knight to c6 will be a
threat for white so to prevent
everything Bishop f6 attacks the night
and also the rook on a 1 is undefended
so nice the c6 now attacking both of the
rooks rook to e8 and now Knight captures
Sun before Bishop captures an a1 and we
have this in game where the material is
pretty equal Tarth would have a past a
point cup of monkey would have a past C
pawn there or both of the pawns are
equally advanced but when you look at it
couple Blancas King is much further away
from tariffs pass pawn the entire scheme
is to combo Blancas passed pawn so if
you you know continue trading pieces and
take this into account white will be
white will be you know do want a favor
here so after this Bishop to b5 first
couple Blanca goes for Bishop captures
on f3 not allowing this entire line
which also comes with the idea that if
Queen captures then white loses a pawn
here and it's also an interesting
interesting line where white gets a lot
of attacking potential for example there
should be three attacks the rook room
before and now Bishop to c6 attacks the
night here now d5 defending the night
and not rook F to D 1 and here white
could what would have a lot of a lot of
potential in the position for for his
pawn sacrifice pawn and also the past a
pawn is still here and the game then
continues it will be somewhat difficult
to defend the d5 pawn but there is a
very nice line Knight c3 attacks the
rook roof d3 attack is the night and now
Queen to b8 here offering a knight with
some ideas of rook to be one check but
white can accept it
rook captures and now Bishop to f6 would
an attack on both rooks
rook to f1 now defending and now Bishop
captures in c3 and now Bishop to c5
attacking both of blacks rooks it's a
pretty crazy line
b4 Bishop captures an F 8 and now rook
to be
threatening to capture and bring the
Queen over to b1 g3 now making some room
for the king
rook captures King captures and only now
Queen captures on f8 and we would have
this position where black keeps his
extra pawn already with a past C pawn
and D pawn and it's a pretty equally
position game so after Bishop captures
an f3 Tyler doesn't go for Queen
captures but the G captures kicks the
knight back and also the Queen now
defends the d4 pawn we have nice the g5
by capablanca but now a tariffs pawn
structure is somewhat to compromise the
in front of the King and you do have to
defend rook to a3 f4 is the idea and
from there the rook will be helping out
with with the defense by covering the
entire third rank Bishop to f6 and now
comes f4 as planned 9 3 6
as you can see Terrace pawn structure is
a bit messed up so those points will be
easy targets
rook to a ch3 here tariffs decides
there's no point in trying to defend the
position anymore Capablanca positional
cover Blanc has just better so tariff
shifts into into attack mode
rook to h3 wood ideas of Queen h5 of
course followed by some checkmating
ideas but couple Blanca says queen h5 is
not a problem and he decides to grab yet
another pawn rook captures done before
is played and now Queen to h5
threatening checkmate on h7 h6 defending
and now comes Luke to g3
what's the idea of of course Queen
captures on h6 the g7 pawn is now no
longer will be able to capture and here
a couple Lanka played King to h8 I'm
pinning the bust also possible was
Knight captures on f4 and now after
Queen captures here just Knight to g6
and it's a pretty nice position there
are no dangerous here for example you
might think ok maybe Roe captures pawn
captures Queen captures but there's
nothing here for white Bishop to c4 is
not not a possibility the row covers
that Square but even without d5 would be
an idea so it would just be a much
better position for black even though it
might seem kind of dangerous but there's
nothing to it so King to h8 first by
capablanca and now comes the Queen to f5
f5 seems like an interesting idea with
the plan but
captures on h6 but it doesn't work black
can simply block this with 95 but also
even better is just rook to h4 the force
is the Queen back and now after the
Queen retreats 94 black defends and and
retains a better position so after King
h8 we have Queen to f5 and now comes
Bishop to h4 attacking the rook and
preparing Queen to f6 Capablanca now
wants to activate the Queen and also
perhaps even trade Queen's rook to h3
and now Queen to f6 and here tarnish
could go for captures captures and f5
and try to try to play this still having
the outside passed pawn but he would be
down in material with somewhat come from
my sponsor on the Kings side it might
might have been playable but still
playing this against capablanca would
pretty much equal suicide and unless
your last girl asked her would to figure
something out so tariff decides he wants
the Queen still on the board he wants to
continue attacking he's not interesting
in in you know suffering a slightly
worse end game against Capablanca for a
very long time queen g4 threatens to
attack the bishop but it's not a problem
the bishop is not lost kappa blanka
simply goes Bishop g5 of course the pawn
cannot capture as rook captures Queen
would be played so Bishop to e3 attacks
capablanca rook but now comes Knight
captures on f4 a very nice idea Bishop
captures with an attack on the Queen but
now Knight captures with check and now
King to h1 if you capture with the Queen
you lose the bishop on d4 so King to h1
now you're a queen is under attack and
also your knight is under attack there
is only one move that prevents both
threats Queen to e6 getting the Queen
ordered way and also helping out with
the defense of the night and here if you
try something like Queen g3 moving the
Queen then black and just push c5 25
check will be a threat so here Lasker
Soros novel Oscar Terra again avoids
that the trade of Queens and goes Queen
to f3 and now comes
Bishop to d2 preventing counter play
also not allowing this pawn to start
marching forward we have Queen to d3
attacking the bishop and now Bishop to
a5 completely block
off the pawn bishop 2c6 now taking hold
of this very important diagonal which
black can use to deliver checks to the
white king but it's only temporarily as
Capablanca now plays d5 completely
blocking off the bishop now and also
threatening to capture it
rook the c1 defending and here
capablanca really starts playing amazing
chess just overloading the position he
plays Knight to f4
the queen is under attack and also you
can see that the queen is guarding the
bishop here so if Queen makes an unwise
retreat for example something like this
then queenie forecheck wins the bishop
on d4 so we have to be very careful and
also you are not really able to move the
rook as rook is forced to keep an eye on
the bishop on c6 so Queen to III not
Irish once the trade Queens but
capablanca is not interested in doing it
right away if you capture then Bishop
captures attacks the knight which
defends the pawn if you move the knight
you lose the pawn so here Tyrus would
still be able to play this game but
after Queen to e3 a kappa blanka finds a
brilliant move that's just a you know a
game ender so feel free to pause the
video here and find this brilliant move
kappa blanka played I'll give you a
couple of seconds as usual so for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
ender of games and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
Knight e 2 is is a possible move with an
attack on the bishop and on the rook but
a much faster idea is Bishop to d2 and
now white just is without move so this
is complete complete overload the
rookies are attacked the Queen is under
attack and there's not nothing to do
here if you just move the Queen which
which tower did but there's not much you
can do if you just capture the Queen it
seems like your troubles are over but
not really Knight captures comes with an
attack on the bishop and also on the
rook and you can't defend both so you'd
have to play some but should be to give
up the exchange and then you're just
gonna lose the game couple mantra is up
upon and up the exchange so this will
not be playable on the other hand after
this Bishop to d2 move you could play
the move
tarus played which is Queen to a3
now with the idea there still poison to
the position you know for example if
Capablanca now captures the rook then
Queen captures on f8 check King moves
and Queen captures and g7 will be
checkmate so you don't want to start
celebrating too early so after Queen to
a3 kappa blanka simply played rook to b8
by far d strongest move taking away even
the b2 Square from from the White Queen
and now there's really nothing for now
for Taurus to do and it was in this
position for the first time has since
the two of them started facing each
other that dr. Siebert arash resigned
the game and couple Lanka takes the lead
you know in in there well a rivalry so
to say why did he resign well now you
just have to decide what the play
there's really not all that much the
rock is still under attack you can't
move the rook because the rook has to
protect the bishop on c6 if you don't do
anything
Queenie for check will be deadly yes the
Queen does cover the f3 square and that
sorry that's I forgot to mention that's
why I rope to f8 was played Queen to e4
check is met with f3 then the check is
blocked and there's still the threat of
Queen captures on f8 so first kappa
blanka just eliminated death threat
that's why i looked to be 8 and now
there are too many threats Queen
captures and c6 will be a threat if the
rook moves if the rook doesn't move then
Bishop captures rook is an idea if you
play anything then Queenie forecheck
picks up the bishop so it would be
impossible to prevent to prevent all
these threats so for example just show
if you play there's no move to play so I
can't show if you play something if you
play like Queen g3 for example Queenie
for just 2 wins wins the bishop if you
try something like rook to c2 like guard
the rook and also maybe guard the bishop
again you get Queen to II 1 checkmated
this is even worse so that's not not not
even an option so I can't even show you
what what could white could try to try
and play because simply everything loses
you can just try some variations for
yourself but yeah excellent game by
Capablanca going into this second part
of the tournament with a point and had
half lead drawing the first game with
world champion Emanuel ask her now
winning for the first time ever against
dr. Zuber Tarek capablanca is just
crushing this tournament so it's gonna
be gonna be a great tournament I do hope
you're enjoying it and that you have
enjoyed this game and my coverage of the
entire capablanca saga so far I would
like to thank Edward Garrett gardening
Barca Darian Paul staples Ismail sail
sail him and Stefan man for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos you're
thinking for watching and I will see you
soon hopefully with some more
interesting content yeah thank you all
and have an excellent rest of your day